[Music]
all right a lot of breaking news we're
going to go slow a lot of details
surrounding this Democratic memo put
together by liberal Trump aiding
congressman Adam Schiff now we'll
dissect this thing point by point we'll
give you all the information that the
media won't tell you about but before we
get into all of those details here is
the biggest takeaway everything from a
year ago that we have been uncovering
and telling you about involving rampant
FISA abuses spying on the Trump campaign
has actually now been corroborated by
the Democrats now it's all true the
shift memo was supposed to take on the
credibility and challenge the memo the
congressman Nunez put out but in reality
the exact opposite is happening now
here's why facts are facts the truth is
the truth both Republicans and Democrats
are now confirming that the completely
unverified Hillary Clinton bought and
paid for dossier filled with Russian
lies made a large part of the FISA
applicate application that was used to
then spy on a member of the Trump
campaign and here's another key point
you have to consider have you noticed
the near radio silence from fake News
CNN conspiracy TV MSNBC when it comes to
the Schiff memo the liberal media
they're not talking about it because
they know that it proves all of the key
findings and facts of the Republican
memos and now that you have that
important background information let's
dive into this democratic memo here's
what this shift memo corroborates just
like the Nunez memo in the house the
Grassley gram memo in the Senate they
lay out the FBI the DOJ did in fact lie
and mislead a FISA judge about the fact
that Hillary Clinton and the DNC that
she controlled actually paid for the
Russian dossier full of lies now shift
he actually quotes a section of the FISA
application and his memo it reads that
the DOJ disclosed the Christopher Steele
was approached by an identified us
person who's indicated a source one
Steele that a us-based law firm had
hired the identified us person to
conduct research regarding candidate
number ones ties to Russia Trump
the identified us person and source
number one have long-standing business
relationship now the identified us
person hired source number one to
conduct the research the identified us
person never advised source number one
as to the motivation behind the research
into candidate ones Trump's ties to
Russia
the FBI speculates the identified us
person was likely looking for
information that could be used to
discredit candidate number ones campaign
now Hillary Clinton
the Clinton campaign the DNC here's the
shock there never mentioned in other
words they are outright lying by
omission slowly in other words it is an
indisputable fact that the FBI DOJ lied
to the FISA judge in order to get a
warrant to spy on Trump campaign
associate he'll join us later Carter
page they purposefully and maliciously
hid all ties the Clinton and the DNC
because there's no way on this green
earth that any FISA judge would ever
have approved the application if in fact
the judge knew that Clinton and the DNC
paid over 12 million dollars for a
dossier to influence the election and
that last sentence about the FBI
speculating about the purpose of the
dossier that's especially important
because that indicates that the FBI and
the DOJ they knew about the political
motivations behind the Russian paid-for
dossier and they used it anyway
it sound like a deep state that key
point has been proven and it's
undoubtedly true now understand how
profound this really is you have the FBI
DOJ they literally knew Hillary Clinton
her campaign and the DNC she's
controlling that they paid for a dossier
filled with Russian lies and Russian
government lies they covered up the fact
before the FISA judge to get the warrant
and in the process what are they really
doing they're shredding the Constitution
our Fourth Amendment protections Schiff
is also exposing himself to be a big fat
liar in the
memo he admits that the dossier had
political motivations but on February
2nd after the Nunez memo came out Shipp
put out a statement that statement reads
in part quote the majority suggest that
the FBI failed to alert the court as to
mr. Steele's potential political
motivations or the political motivations
of those who hired him but this is
inaccurate
so Schiff is saying something that is an
outright lie
now there's the proof and here's the
other key point the shift memo was
corroborating the newness and the
Grassley grand memos because they expose
how the dossier was the essential part
of the FISA application and if you look
at the Grassley Graham memo if I quote
their words the bulk of the FISA
application consisted of the unverified
Clinton bought and paid for dossier Wow
now Shipp tries to downplay the reliance
on the phony dossier by writing in his
memo that had only made up a narrow part
of the FISA application that too is a
lie and Shipp also writes that a
specific section of the FISA application
actually references the completely
unverified claims in the dossier about
Carter page and June 20 at 26 June 2016
in the meetings that he had in Moscow
page has denied over and over again it's
never been confirmed so ship is
admitting the contrary to his claims the
dossier did make up the bulk of the
application to get the FISA warrant now
the Democrats current position on the
dossier and look they're trying to
minimize it is the complete opposite of
what they were saying back in March
during a congressional hearing there all
this is all politics they're all liars
and they're all phony and we've been
right for a year now take a look at this
according to Christopher Steele a
British a former British intelligence
officer who was reportedly held in high
regard by US intelligence Russian
sources tell him that Paige has also had
a secret meeting with Igor Sechin
according to Steel's Russian sources
pages offered brokerage fees by section
also according to Steel's Russian
sources the campaign is offered
documents damaging
Hilary Clinton according to steel it was
mana Ford who chose Paige to serve as a
go-between for the Trump campaign and
Russian interests my focus today is
explore how many claims within Steel's
dossier are looking more and more likely
as though they are accurate the
reputation of the author Christopher
steel is a former accomplished British
intelligence officer with a career built
on following Russia is important this is
not someone who doesn't know how to run
a source and not someone without
contacts they know better now former
federal prosecutor Andy McCarthy and
other legal experts are also pointing to
a very key fact in order to get the FISA
warrant approved because Paige Carter
paid he'll join us in a minute as an
American citizen well the FBI and the
DOJ had to show the page was acting as
an agent of a foreign government and
that is clandestine actions to help
Russia were likely a violation of
federal law now as we have been
reporting on the dossier put the FISA
warrant over the top without the dossier
they wouldn't have been able to get any
judge to sign off on the warrant we've
also been telling you that the FISA
application remember it was denied the
first and probably the second time but
then in the dossier was used to help win
approval as a matter of fact it was the
bulk of it and it's probably why the new
Ness memo says that the former deputy
FBI director Andrew McCabe he testified
without the dossier a judge would never
had granted a FISA warrant to surveil
Carter page and by the way they wouldn't
have even tried for the FISA warrant and
speaking of mccabe after the new Ness
memo was released democrats accused
Nunez of lying about McCabe's testimony
on the dossier interesting the shift
memo doesn't offer up any evidence to
refute that
now if newness was wrong well why didn't
share from the Democrats include a
transcript about what McCabe said to
prove the point my sources tell me that
McCabe said that and much more Democrats
didn't do it for the obvious reason
because the facts aren't on their side
now the shift memo also tries to make a
big deal about Steele's credibility
given the fact that he had worked in the
past with the FBI now shifts trying to
change the subject here and hide the
fact that Steele used
current and former Russian government
sources in the dossier and that none of
the information this is the important
part none of it was ever verified by the
FBI
it was never verified by the Department
of Justice by fusion GPS which hired
steel in other words when getting a FISA
warrant the credibility of the person is
not nearly as important as the
credibility of the sources of where the
information is coming from and as we've
been telling you none of the information
from Russian sources was ever
corroborated none of it so ship and the
Democrats clearly are trying to conceal
this most important fact from you the
American people here's another key truth
the shift memo confirms about the two
Republican memos the GOP memos detail
how the FISA application mentions that
Yahoo News article written by Michael
Isikoff about Carter page but what ship
flies about is that Steele was the
source for izikoff and Yahoo News which
the FISA judge was not made aware of
he's like thinking these are two
independent corroborating sources no one
source same person and the Republican
memos explained how the Yahoo News
article was used to independently
corroborate Steele's dossier as another
source but Steele was the only source
another light of the judge and another
yet key aspect of all this is the ship
memo is admitting to be true and that is
that the former British spy Christopher
Steele remember why was he terminated as
an FBI source oh he was leaking to the
media and what ship and the Democrats
can conveniently leave out is that
Steele lie to the FBI about talking to
the press and bringing this information
to them which is why senator Grassley
and Senator Graham have made a criminal
referral against Christopher Steele the
shift' memo is full of other massive and
outright lies as well for example Schiff
falsely claims the Carter page was never
spied on while the member of the Trump
campaign that's not true because with a
FISA warrant the federal government has
the ability to access all of pages old
electronic communications all the emails
all tech messages all
phone calls when he was a part of the
Trump campaign and that means that yes
the FBI spied on the Trump campaign and
getting the warrant on page allowed them
to do it which is why they lied for to
get the FISA warrant in the first place
and Paige will join us and explain later
on now if the guy was a Russian spy
Carter page liked the shift memos
claiming why hasn't Carter page been
charged with the crime and if the
evidence against page is so overwhelming
you know that the FBI didn't need the
phony dossier to get a warrant again
just like Schiff and the Democrats are
claiming then why was it used now
shipwrights the Carter page actually
talked to the FBI in March of 2016 so
after the FBI got the dossier months
later why wouldn't they just go to talk
to Paige again and find out what he knew
he cooperated in March getting a FISA
warrant on an American citizen is
supposed to be the last resort it should
only be necessary when the foreign
intelligence that the government is
seeking cannot be obtained through
normal investigative techniques from
what we now know the FBI didn't get in
contact with Paige again when the bureau
apparently got their hands on the phony
dossier in the fall of 2016 only months
before the election now why wouldn't the
FBI do that when Paige had already been
cooperating none of this makes sense and
then again maybe it isn't supposed to
because the truth is finally coming out
here's the bottom line
the FBI top echelon not rank and file
lied to a FISA judge about Clinton and
the DNC they never told the judge that
she paid for these Russian lies in this
dossier that was then used to get a
warrant to spy on the Trump campaign it
is should be D it is one if not the
biggest political scandal in our history